The first dream that we have on record was dreamed by a woman, and her name was Aduduri, and she was the overseer of the palace of Mari in Mesopotamia. More than 3,000 years ago, she etched a letter onto clay tablets describing what she saw. In my dream I had gone into the temple of the goddess Belit al-Aquim, and the statue of Belit Akhalim wasn't there, nor were the statues of the other divinities that normally stand beside her. Faced with this sight, I wept and wept. George Steiner observed something profound about this dream.
我们记录下的第一个梦是由一位女性所做的，她的名字叫阿杜杜里（Aduduri），她是美索不达米亚马里王宫的监工。三千多年前，她在泥板上刻下了一封信，描述了她所见到的景象：“在梦中，我走进了贝利特·阿奎姆（Belit al-Aquim）女神的神庙，贝利特·阿哈利姆（Belit Akhalim）的雕像不在那里，通常站在她身边的其他神灵的雕像也不见了。”面对此景，我痛哭流涕。乔治·斯坦纳（George Steiner）对这个梦观察到了深刻的见解。
The first of all dreams speaks of an empty temple. Loss precedes presence, and every image must abide by this rule. Think about what Aaduduri was experiencing. She walks into a space that should be full of meaning, full of the containers that holds her culture's understanding of itself, and they are gone. The gods have been dragged away, and all that she can do is weep. This is the thesis of this entire,
所有梦境中的第一个梦，讲述的是一座空荡荡的神庙。失去先于存在，每一个意象都必须遵循这一法则。想想阿杜杜里当时正在经历什么。她走进了一个本应充满意义的空间，充满了承载她文化自我认知的容器，但它们却消失了。神灵被拖走了，她所能做的只有哭泣。这就是整个系列的论点，
series. What happens when you strip context from consciousness? What happens when you take away the metaphors that allow us to function, to project ourselves onto something larger than ourselves, to make sense of existence? What Adu Duri experiences in that empty temple is something very close to madness. A retreat entirely into this objective is insane. And this person who believes that their feelings are reality, who can't distinguish between what they imagine, in what is, this is psychosis in its clinical sense. Someone who is so lost in the inner world that they've lost contact with a shared world that could encounter another person. They are alone.
系列。当你从意识中剥离语境时会发生什么？当你拿走那些让我们能够运作、让我们将自己投射到比自身更宏大的事物上、让我们理解存在的隐喻时，会发生什么？阿杜杜里在那座空神庙里的经历，非常接近疯狂。完全退缩到这种客观性中是疯狂的。而这个认为自己的感受就是现实、无法区分想象与现实的人，在临床意义上就是精神病。一个人在内心世界中迷失得太深，以至于失去了与能够遇见另一个人的共享世界的联系。他们是孤独的。
But a retreat entirely into the objective is also insane. And this is the person who believes only what can be counted is real, who can't access their own felt experience, who is trying to be what everyone needs them to be and forgot who they were. someone's so lost in measurement and abstraction that they've lost contact with lived reality, and they are also isolated, alone, and stripped of context. Both are forms of the same dissolution, and both are failures to maintain the bridge between the inner and the outer world. Sanity is the capacity to move between the subjective and the objective, to hold them in tension and to use each to check the other.
但完全退缩到客观性中也是疯狂的。这就是那种只相信可量化事物才是真实的人，他们无法触及自己的真实感受，试图成为每个人需要他们成为的样子，却忘记了自己是谁。一个人在测量和抽象中迷失得太深，以至于失去了与现实生活的联系，他们同样被孤立、孤独，并被剥夺了语境。两者都是同一种瓦解的形式，都是未能维持内心世界与外部世界之间桥梁的失败。理智是在主观与客观之间游走的能力，是将它们保持在张力之中，并用两者相互校验的能力。
Sanity is a metaphor. Sanity is a symbol. sanity is the ability to stand in the temple and know that the statue is not the god but also know that the statue matters that it points to one and we built a temple you know a mental health system that pushes people towards the objectivity that is driving us insane while claiming to cure them of this objective and we've emptied the temple and called it treatment welcome to the taproot therapy podcast and discover he'll grow this is true Joel Blackstock, and this concludes our series on the DSM and the quantification of consciousness. The historian that I talk about a lot, Theodore Porter, wrote a book called Trust in Numbers, and that explains exactly how this happened.
理智是一种隐喻。理智是一种象征。理智是站在神庙中，既知道雕像不是神，又知道雕像很重要，因为它指向神的能力。我们建造了一座神庙，你知道，一个心理健康系统，它在声称治愈人们的同时，却将人们推向了让我们发疯的客观性，我们清空了神庙，并称之为治疗。欢迎来到Taproot Therapy播客，我是Joel Blackstock，本期节目结束了我们关于DSM（精神疾病诊断与统计手册）和意识量化的系列节目。我经常提到的历史学家西奥多·波特（Theodore Porter）写过一本书叫《信任数字》（Trust in Numbers），书中准确解释了这一切是如何发生的。
Porter makes this distinction that's crucial. He separates disciplinary objectivity from mechanical objectivity. Disciplinary objectivity is what works in high trust communities. It relies on trained judgment, experts who share a task. understanding of what constitutes valid knowledge and they don't need a checklist to agree on what they see their shared training and socialization provides the standard and this is how psychoanalysis used to work the authority of the analyst was personal it came from training lineage clinical experience reputation
波特做了一个至关重要的区分。他将学科客观性与机械客观性分离开来。学科客观性在高度信任的社区中有效。它依赖于训练有素的判断力，依赖于对什么是有效知识有共同理解的专家，他们不需要清单就能对所见达成共识，他们共同的训练和社会化提供了标准。这就是精神分析曾经的工作方式，分析师的权威是个人化的，它源于训练、传承、临床经验和声誉。
within the guild mechanical objectivity is different rigid adherence to explicit rules algorithms standardized protocols it tries to eliminate what Porter calls the personal equation The idiosyncrasies of the individual observer so that any two people following the same rules arrive at the same result. Here's Porter's crucial insight. Mechanical objectivity is not pursued by the strongest scientists. Sciences. It's pursued by the weakest and most insecure forms of science.
在行业内部，机械客观性则不同：它严格遵守明确的规则、算法和标准化协议。它试图消除波特所说的“个人方程”，即个体观察者的特质，以便任何两个遵循相同规则的人都能得出相同的结果。这是波特的关键洞见：机械客观性并非由最强大的科学所追求，而是由最薄弱、最不自信的科学形式所追求。
Soft science. When a discipline is vulnerable to external criticism, political pressure, or internal fragmentation, it retreats to mechanical objectivity. to defend itself against charges of arbitrariness. And Porter writes, objectivity lends authority to officials who have very little of their own. And this is not a story about science getting better. It's a story about institutions getting scared. In the 1970s, psychiatry faced a legitimate crisis. The Rosenhan study sent sane people into hospitals that they couldn't tell, you know,
软科学。当一个学科容易受到外部批评、政治压力或内部碎片化的影响时，它就会退缩到机械客观性，以捍卫自己免受随意性的指控。波特写道：“客观性为那些本身几乎没有权威的官员提供了权威。”这不是一个科学变得更好的故事，而是一个机构变得恐惧的故事。在20世纪70年代，精神病学面临着合法的危机。罗森汉恩（Rosenhan）实验将正常人送进医院，而医院却无法分辨，你知道，
whether or not the people were sane. And the anti-psychiatry movement called psychiatry movement called psychiatry. a tool of social control. Insurance companies demanded accountability, the same that they would have for pills or surgery. And the response was the DSM-3. They purged the etiology of the theory, you know, and all of the contentious stuff
这些人是否正常。反精神病学运动称精神病学是社会控制的工具。保险公司要求问责，就像对待药丸或手术一样。回应就是DSM-3。他们清除了理论的病因学，你知道，以及所有关于精神疾病成因的争议性内容，
about what causes mental illness. And they replaced it with symptom checklists. Must have five of the following nine for at least two weeks. And the goal was reliability. If two psychiatrists saw the same patient, they should arrive at the same diagnosis. but this was not discovering disease entities. It was a bureaucratic fortification.
并用症状清单取而代之。必须在以下九项中符合五项，且持续至少两周。目标是可靠性。如果两位精神科医生看到同一位病人，他们应该得出相同的诊断。但这并不是在发现疾病实体，而是一种官僚主义的防御。
By creating a rigid manual, psychiatry insulated itself from the charge of subjectivity. It allowed the profession to interfere or interface with the insurance companies and not be interfered with at a judgment-based level by insurance and the FDA. The manual became a technology of trust, not a trust in a doctor, but a trust in a code. And here's the strategy that Porter would say illuminates the trade-off between reality. He would say that there's a trade-off between reliability and validity. Reliability is consistency. We all agree that this is major depressive disorder. Validity is truth.
通过创建一本僵化的手册，精神病学将自己与主观性的指控隔离开来。它允许该行业与保险公司对接，而不受保险公司和FDA在基于判断层面的干预。这本手册成为了一种信任的技术，不是对医生的信任，而是对代码的信任。这是波特所说的阐明现实之间权衡的策略。他会说，可靠性和有效性之间存在权衡。可靠性是连贯性。我们都同意这是重度抑郁症。有效性是真理。
And this label actually corresponds to something real. You can have one without the other. But in pursuing reliability, psychiatry sacrifice to validity. and the categories became socially valid. Insurance insurers accepted them, but biologically invalid. They don't carve nature at its joints. In 2013, the National Institute of Mental Health declared that the DSM was scientifically invalid, but nothing changed clinically because the DSM's purpose was never scientific validity.
这个标签确实对应着某种真实的东西。你可以拥有其中之一而没有另一个。但在追求可靠性的过程中，精神病学牺牲了有效性。这些类别在社会上是有效的，保险公司接受它们，但在生物学上是无效的。它们并没有切中自然的关节。2013年，美国国家心理健康研究所宣布DSM在科学上是无效的，但临床上没有任何改变，因为DSM的目的从来都不是科学有效性。
It was bureaucratic legitimacy. And they emptied the temple to survive. Now, here's a big point to understand. You know, it's easy to hear all this and think that I'm describing a conspiracy, but I'm not. Most people in the system aren't villains. They're not consciously hiding biases for profit. The insurance executives, the academics, the researchers, the clinicians following protocols. Most of them genuinely believe that they're being rigorous.
它是官僚主义的合法性。他们为了生存清空了神庙。现在，这是一个需要理解的重点。你知道，听到这一切很容易认为我在描述一个阴谋，但我不是。系统中的大多数人不是恶棍。他们并没有为了利润而有意识地隐藏偏见。保险高管、学者、研究人员、遵循协议的临床医生。他们大多数人真诚地相信自己是在严谨行事。
The genuine belief, they genuinely believe that they are being scientific. And that's what makes this tragic instead of merely corrupt. They've lost faith in what they can't see. think about what it means to trust trained judgment. It means believing that a person through years of formation and experience can perceive truths that can't be reduced to a checklist. It means believing in something invisible, the cultivation of wisdom, the development of clinical intuition, the ineffable quality of the therapeutic presence. That requires faith, faith in human capacity, faith in the intangible, and somewhere along the way that faith broke. When you lose faith in the invisible, you lose faith in the invisible, you,
他们真诚地相信自己是在进行科学研究。这正是让这件事变得悲剧而非仅仅是腐败的原因。他们失去了对看不见之物的信仰。想想信任训练有素的判断力意味着什么。这意味着相信一个人通过多年的塑造和经验，可以感知到无法简化为清单的真理。这意味着相信某种无形的东西，智慧的培养，临床直觉的发展，治疗存在中那种不可言说的品质。这需要信仰，对人类能力的信仰，对无形之物的信仰，而在某个过程中，这种信仰破灭了。当你失去对无形之物的信仰时，你，
You don't stop believing in it. You transfer your faith to whatever is visible. And so the PHQ9 score becomes more real than the patient's suffering. Or the story that the patient is telling and the diagnostic code becomes more real than the person. The randomized controlled trial becomes more real than what happens in the room. And the system becomes more than reality itself. And this isn't corruption. It's a civilizational loss of faith in the invisible.
你并没有停止相信它。你将你的信仰转移到了任何可见的事物上。因此，PHQ9分数变得比病人的痛苦更真实。或者病人讲述的故事，诊断代码变得比人本身更真实。随机对照试验变得比房间里发生的事情更真实。系统变得比现实本身更重要。这不是腐败。这是一种文明对无形之物的信仰丧失。
And the people inside the system can't see their own assumptions anymore because they've dressed them in the costume of objectivity. And the blind spots fill up. We can't see them. So we think that we can see everything, because we can't see what we can't see. And this pattern shows up throughout history when civilizations lose faith in the invisible.
系统内部的人再也看不见他们自己的假设了，因为他们给这些假设穿上了客观性的外衣。盲点填满了。我们看不见它们。所以我们认为我们可以看见一切，因为我们看不见我们看不见的东西。当文明失去对无形之物的信仰时，这种模式在整个历史上都会出现。
You know, late in Rome, they maintained elaborate bureaucratic forms long after the substance was gone. The offices still had titles, the procedures still had steps, the forms got filled out, but the meaning behind them evaporated. They kept the forms because the forms were visible
你知道，在罗马帝国晚期，即使实质早已消失，他们仍维持着复杂的官僚形式。职位依然有头衔，程序依然有步骤，表格依然被填满，但背后的意义却蒸发了。他们保留了表格，因为表格是可见的，
and the substance required faith that they no longer had in an empire that had fallen. You know, the Soviet Union knew the five-year plan had these quotas and there were lies. Everyone knew that. The factory managers knew, the party officials knew, the workers knew, but they maintained the quotas, falsified the reports, performed the rituals of productivity because the alternative was admitting that there was nothing underneath. The numbers had become more real than reality, and dismantling them would expose the void. And then there's cargo cults. You know, during the World War II, American troops landed on islands in the South Pacific.
而实质需要一种他们在一个已经衰落的帝国中不再拥有的信仰。你知道，苏联知道五年计划有这些配额，而且存在谎言。每个人都知道。工厂经理知道，党内官员知道，工人们知道，但他们维持着配额，伪造报告，表演生产力的仪式，因为另一种选择是承认下面什么都没有。数字变得比现实更真实，拆除它们会暴露虚空。还有货物崇拜。你知道，二战期间，美军登陆南太平洋的岛屿。
Melanesia, Vanuatu, I'm not sure how to say that one. I think it's Vanuatu. Places that had never seen, you know, industrial civilization, they built air strips. They set up radio towers. And when the planes landed, they brought cargo. Food, medicine, chocolate, Coca-Cola. And these islanders had never seen any of the stuff. And the soldiers were generous that shared what they had when the plane landed with the supplies.
美拉尼西亚，瓦努阿图，我不确定那个怎么说。我想是瓦努阿图。那些从未见过工业文明的地方，他们建造了简易机场。他们架设了无线电塔。当飞机降落时，它们带来了货物。食物、药品、巧克力、可口可乐。这些岛民从未见过这些东西。士兵们很慷慨，当飞机降落时，他们分享了带来的补给。
and the islanders watched everything and they watched the men sit in the huts with little pieces on their head and they watched them talk into boxes, you know, headphones and radios. And they watched them spin cranks and wave flags. And then the planes would come. And then the war ended and the soldiers left, so the cargo stopped coming. When the anthropologists went back years later, they found the islanders had built their own airstrip.
岛民们观察着一切，他们看着男人们坐在小屋里，头上戴着小东西，他们看着他们对着盒子说话，你知道，耳机和收音机。他们看着他们转动曲柄，挥舞旗帜。然后飞机就会来。后来战争结束了，士兵们离开了，所以货物停止了运送。多年后人类学家回去时，发现岛民们建造了自己的简易机场。
They'd cleared the jungle and made runways. And they'd built wooden control towers and they'd carved headphones out of coconut shells and then made antennas out of bamboo. and they sat in their huts and they talked to rocks, and they waved landing signals at the empty sky. And Richard Feynman, the physicist, gave a commencement speech at Caltech in 1974. He said, in the South Seas, there is a cargo cult of people, and during the war they saw airplanes land with lots of goods and materials,
他们清理了丛林，铺设了跑道。他们建造了木制的控制塔，用椰子壳雕刻了耳机，用竹子制作了天线。他们坐在小屋里，对着石头说话，向空荡荡的天空挥舞着降落信号。物理学家理查德·费曼（Richard Feynman）在1974年加州理工学院的毕业典礼上发表了演讲。他说，在南海，有一种货物崇拜的人，战争期间他们看到飞机降落，带来了大量的货物和材料，
and they wanted the same thing to happen now. So they've arranged to make things like runways, to put fires along the sides of the runways, to make a wooden hut for a man to sit in with two wooden pieces on his, had like a headphone and bars of bamboo sticks sticking out like antennas. He's the controller. And they wait for the airplanes to land. They're doing everything right. The form is perfect. It looks exactly the way that it should, the way that it looked before. But it doesn't work because no airplanes land. And a fine man called this the cargo cult science, following all the
他们现在也想发生同样的事情。所以他们安排建造像跑道一样的东西，在跑道两侧点火，建造一个木屋让一个人坐在里面，头上戴着两个木片，像耳机一样，竹竿像天线一样伸出来。他是控制员。他们等待飞机降落。他们做的一切都是对的。形式是完美的。它看起来完全像它应该有的样子，像以前看起来的样子。但它不起作用，因为没有飞机降落。费曼称之为“货物崇拜科学”，遵循所有
apparent forms of scientific investigation while missing something essential. He was talking about psychology. He said that the first principle is that you must not fool yourself, and you are the easiest person to fool. Never underestimate how a little group of people who think that they're smart and take themselves very seriously can actually know. When I was a kid, there was this guy who has this, he was huge in evangelical circles, James Dobson, focus on the family. And he did all these books and seminars about raising children to be Christian and accountable. And the motto of the movement was break the will of the child. You know, the child was bad,
科学调查的表面形式，却缺失了本质的东西。他当时谈论的是心理学。他说第一原则是你绝不能欺骗自己，而你是最容易被欺骗的人。永远不要低估一群自认为聪明且非常严肃对待自己的人实际上能知道什么。我小时候，有个家伙在福音派圈子里很有名，詹姆斯·多布森（James Dobson），《爱家协会》（Focus on the Family）。他写了所有关于培养基督徒和负责任的孩子书籍和研讨会。该运动的座右铭是“打破孩子的意志”。你知道，孩子是坏的，
and if you made it subservient, you know, it was, how could the child serve the God if they can't even serve the father? So you teach them obedience through discipline. And Dobson advocated for spanking children as young as 15 months old,
如果你让他们顺从，你知道，如果他们连父亲都不能侍奉，他们怎么能侍奉上帝呢？所以你通过纪律教导他们服从。多布森主张对年仅15个月大的孩子进行打屁股，
and he wrote about escalating punishment until there was crying, genuine tears, is what he would call it, not pretend tears. They have to actually be completely disregulated. And, you know, there was a thing
他写道要升级惩罚直到孩子哭泣，他称之为真正的眼泪，而不是假装的眼泪。他们必须真正完全失控。而且，你知道，有一件事
that he also would say, was that if the baby was crying, but it wasn't meal time, an infant, you should give it water to show that you heard it. But you shouldn't give it milk because it wasn't meal time. And you were trying to teach it that it was crying at the wrong time, you know. We know infants, they need food. They don't even know that they're separate from the mother. They just want warmth and love and food. You know, and Dobson says, when your baby cries, just give it water. to show it that it's not controlling you.
他也会说，如果婴儿在哭，但不是吃饭时间，你应该给它水来表明你听到了。但你不应该给它奶，因为那不是吃饭时间。你是在试图教导它在错误的时间哭泣，你知道。我们知道婴儿，他们需要食物。他们甚至不知道自己与母亲是分开的。他们只是想要温暖、爱和食物。你知道，多布森说，当你的孩子哭时，只给它水，以表明它不能控制你。
You know, it's an ego battle with a creature that doesn't have an ego. Like a dog knows how to nurse its babies. And we get a whole bunch of people in a room who sat down completely objectively, through logic and ego, came up with a way to break that inborn nature and to be cut off from it. There's a metaphor from visual science, neuroscience,
你知道，这是一种与没有自我的生物进行的自我斗争。就像狗知道如何喂养它的幼崽。我们让一群人坐在房间里，完全客观地，通过逻辑和自我，想出了一种打破那种与生俱来的本性并与之隔绝的方法。视觉科学、神经科学中有一个隐喻，
that explains why people inside the systems generally can't see what they're doing. The lacuna is the spot in your eye where the optic nerve enters the eye to carry the message back to the subcortical brain, 90% of it, and then 10% goes directly, and the rest of it goes to occipital, where an image gets resolved.
解释了为什么系统内部的人通常看不见他们在做什么。盲点（lacuna）是你眼睛里视神经进入眼睛将信息传回皮层下大脑（90%）的地方，然后10%直接进入，其余的进入枕叶，在那里图像被解析。
And the eye is literally blind there. It can't see anything. There's a hole in your vision right now, but your brain confabulates vision in that spot. It takes everything around the blind spot, and it fills it in like a Photoshop filter. And you can't see that, even if you try. The confabulation is seamless.
眼睛在那里确实是盲的。它什么也看不见。你的视野里现在有一个洞，但你的大脑在那个点上编造了视觉。它获取盲点周围的一切，并像Photoshop滤镜一样填充它。即使你尝试，你也看不见。这种编造是无缝的。
You can look at the center of your vision and you have no idea where it is. And this is what institutions do. They fill in their blind spots with assumptions, assumptions dressed as facts. The pharmaceutical researcher doesn't see their funding source as bias because they've defined methodology in a way that excludes that excludes that consideration. The blind spot fills itself in. The academic doesn't see their career investment as bias because they've defined evidence in a way that only includes certain evidence and excludes others. So it's not evidence.
你可以看着你视野的中心，你根本不知道它在哪里。这就是机构所做的。他们用假设填补他们的盲点，这些假设被包装成事实。制药研究人员看不见他们的资金来源是偏见，因为他们定义方法论的方式排除了那种考虑。盲点自动填补。学者看不见他们的职业投资是偏见，因为他们定义证据的方式只包含某些证据而排除了其他证据。所以这不是证据。
I'm not going to look at it, except it's evidence that you're wrong. You're just not looking at it. And they look at certain evidence very correctly, and the blind spot fills up. And the insurance company doesn't see the profit motive as biased because they've defined responsible care in a way that aligns with their bottom line. And the ultimate purpose of their organization is to make money. So how could they examine that? The blind spot fills up. They genuinely can't see it.
我不打算看它，除非它是你错了的证据。你只是没在看它。他们非常正确地看待某些证据，盲点就填满了。保险公司看不见利润动机是偏见，因为他们定义负责任的护理方式与他们的底线一致。而他们组织最终的目的是赚钱。所以他们怎么能审视这一点呢？盲点填满了。他们真诚地看不见。
The lacuna is invisible to the eye that has it, and all eyes have it. And this is why the system can't reform itself. from within. The people inside are looking through eyes that have blind spots in exactly the same places that they'd need to see to make change. And they're performing the rituals of science with genuine sincerity. And they never notice that the substance has been replaced by procedure. And the only way to see a blind spot is through another perspective. Multiple eyes can map the visual field completely, even though no single eye can see everything. Which is why this conversation has to happen outside of that system.
盲点对于拥有它的眼睛来说是不可见的，而所有的眼睛都有它。这就是为什么系统无法从内部自我改革。内部的人透过眼睛看，这些眼睛在他们需要看见以做出改变的地方恰好有盲点。他们以真诚的态度表演科学的仪式。他们从未注意到实质已被程序所取代。看见盲点的唯一方法是通过另一个视角。多只眼睛可以完整地映射视野，尽管没有单只眼睛能看见一切。这就是为什么这场对话必须在系统之外进行。
You know, here's what actually works in therapy, what's always worked. What keeps getting discovered over and over across cultures and centuries by people who never met each other. These are perennial philosophies. They recur because they're pointing at something true about consciousness itself.
你知道，这就是治疗中真正有效的东西，一直有效的东西。这是跨越文化和世纪，被从未见过面的人反复发现的东西。这些是永恒的哲学。它们反复出现是因为它们指向了关于意识本身的某种真实的东西。
If this weren't a story that the deep brain is telling us from behind the scenes, then we wouldn't keep rediscovering it. That is a recurrent form of evidence, objective evidence, but it requires your subjectivity to see what these people are saying.
如果这不是深层大脑在幕后告诉我们的故事，那么我们就不会不断地重新发现它。这是一种反复出现的证据形式，客观证据，但它需要你的主观性才能看到这些人所说的话。
And it's evidence that can't be seen from the distance of pure objectivity. The problem is that different traditions aren't using the same language. And they're not all saying, here's the Sudskore I invented in ancient Babylon and then Carl Jung invented in his study. They're describing subjective spaces
这是从纯粹客观性的距离无法看到的证据。问题在于不同的传统没有使用相同的语言。他们并不是都在说，这是我在古巴比伦发明的苏美尔分数，然后荣格在他的书房里发明的。他们正在描述主观空间，
phenomenologically through metaphor. But when they do that, if you can't read metaphor, if you can't see it, which I'm arguing, we are losing the capacity to do rapidly, then you can see, you can't see that they're talking about the same phenomena.
通过隐喻进行现象学描述。但当他们这样做时，如果你不能阅读隐喻，如果你看不见它——我主张我们正在迅速失去这种能力——那么你就看不见他们在谈论相同的现象。
Plato was already saying these things. Competing drives, multiplicity, the need for integration, the importance of knowing myself, the allegory of the cave, which is basically just a description of how unconscious assumptions shape our perception. And we act like every new therapeutic modality in this system is completely separate. And in this invention that came out of nowhere, they came out of a lab stripped of context or any history. But the parts that work have always been doing these things.
柏拉图已经在说这些事情了。相互竞争的驱动力、多样性、整合的需要、了解自己的重要性、洞穴寓言，这基本上只是关于无意识假设如何塑造我们感知的描述。我们表现得好像这个系统中的每一个新的治疗模式都是完全独立的。在这个凭空出现的发明中，它们来自一个被剥离了语境或任何历史的实验室。但有效的部分一直都在做这些事情。
therapy did not invent therapy it's always been with us you know first metacognition getting outside your head developing the capacity to observe your own mental processes rather than identifying with one single part of what you were feeling learning that it is just part of a part of you and this is meditation this is mindfulness this is freuds where it was their ego shall be this is jung's individuation this is cbt's cognitive restructuring which it works, all pointing at the same thing. But in a purely cognitive behavioral vacuum, it's hard to do metacognition if you don't understand multiplicity of parts because you're thinking, I'm one thing, thinking this thing, now, how do I change that? And you can't back up from yourself
治疗并没有发明治疗，它一直伴随着我们。你知道，首先是元认知，走出你的头脑，发展观察你自己心理过程的能力，而不是认同你所感受到的单一部分，学习它只是你的一部分，这是冥想，这是正念，这是弗洛伊德的“本我所在，自我应在”，这是荣格的个体化，这是CBT的认知重构，它们都指向同一件事。但在一个纯粹的认知行为真空中，如果你不理解部分的多样性，就很难进行元认知，因为你在想，我是一个整体，正在想这件事，现在，我该如何改变它？你无法从你自己身上退后，
when you are yourself completely. The brain has competing networks of consciousness. And it's not one monad that are different systems with different agendas, and you need a framework to discover that. Second, somatics, the way the body stores energy and emotion and pre-budgets it in anticipation of what you need to feel to solve a problem later based on subtle clues. You've got to bring in the fact that the body feels emotion before the mind knows it's there. Even Wilhelm Reich was right about this. As crazy as he got by the end, you know, he didn't get that wrong. And this is Pearls' body awareness. And this is Levine's, you know, somatic experiencing. This is polyvagal theory, porges. The body keeps the score, Vandercolt.
当你完全就是你自己时。大脑有相互竞争的意识网络。它不是一个单子，而是具有不同议程的不同系统，你需要一个框架来发现这一点。第二，躯体学，身体储存能量和情绪的方式，并根据微妙的线索预先预算你为了以后解决问题所需要感受的东西。你必须引入这样一个事实：身体在头脑知道它存在之前就感受到了情绪。即使威廉·赖希（Wilhelm Reich）在这点上也是对的。尽管他到最后变得很疯狂，你知道，他并没有弄错这一点。这是珀尔斯（Perls）的身体意识。这是莱文（Levine）的躯体体验。这是多迷走神经理论，波吉斯（Porges）。身体记录了分数，范德考克（Vanderkolk）。
You know, third, shortcuts and biohacks, EMDR, brain spotting, polyvagal resets, ice baths, tricks that separate you from this stuff quickly as like a little trick to get some buy-in so that you can start to feel how your brain works. But, you know, even the shortcuts that I talk about, brain spotting, ETT, all that stuff, they're not going to help you if you've completely deconstructed who you are. They're not going to help you accept the truth that you've uncovered. that's always going to be the role of a trained therapist. It's always going to be the subjective storyteller function
你知道，第三，捷径和生物黑客，EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工）、脑点疗法（Brainspotting）、多迷走神经重置、冰浴，这些技巧能让你迅速与这些东西分离，就像一个小技巧来获得一些认同，这样你就可以开始感受你的大脑是如何工作的。但是，你知道，即使是我谈到的那些捷径，脑点疗法、ETT等等，如果你已经完全解构了你是谁，它们也不会帮助你。它们不会帮助你接受你所揭示的真相。那永远是训练有素的治疗师的角色。那永远是主观讲故事的功能，
that's helping you understand what's going on in your mind and making you a collaborator in that project because there is no formula for meaning. And that's the point. You know, my wife's a teacher and one of the things that drives me nuts is how we'll spend, as a contrary, millions of dollars on studies proving that some new educational platform made by a private contractor needs to go into schools because it's more effective.
它帮助你理解你头脑中正在发生的事情，并使你成为那个项目中的合作者，因为意义没有公式。这就是重点。你知道，我妻子是一名教师，让我抓狂的一件事是，我们作为一个国家，会花费数百万美元进行研究，证明某种由私人承包商制作的新教育平台需要进入学校，因为它更有效。
All the data in education, going back to the beginning of time, says that if a class is smaller, because you hired more teachers, the students do better. No matter what you teach, no matter how you teach it, no matter what technology you have, even if the teacher is incompetent, smaller classes mean better outcomes. But we put millions into the system that let classes have 50 students, 60 students, and exhaust the good teachers until they leave because the science says that that works. When we know what the science says, we just don't want to do it because we'd rather pay Pearson Hall. Same thing in psychotherapy.
教育领域的所有数据，追溯到时间之初，都表明如果班级规模更小，因为你雇佣了更多的老师，学生表现就会更好。无论你教什么，无论你如何教，无论你有什么技术，即使老师不称职，更小的班级意味着更好的结果。但我们将数百万投入到让班级有50名、60名学生的系统中，并耗尽优秀的老师直到他们离开，因为科学说这有效。当我们知道科学说了什么时，我们只是不想做，因为我们宁愿付钱给Pearson Hall。心理治疗中也是如此。
We know the therapeutic relationship predicts outcomes better than technique, better than the competence of the therapist. And we know smaller caseloads produce better results. We know what works is presence, attunement, the quality of the encounter between two humans. But that can't be manualized. It can't travel across bureaucratic distance and it can't be awesome. audited by people with no clinical understanding who are some reason this middleman involved in paying bills. So we build wooden control towers and we wait for planes that never come. And here's what we forgot about why objectivity exists when we talk about it.
我们知道治疗关系比技术、比治疗师的能力更能预测结果。我们知道更小的病例量会产生更好的结果。我们知道有效的是存在、调谐、两个人之间相遇的质量。但这无法手册化。它无法跨越官僚距离，也无法被审计，因为审计人员没有临床理解力，而中间人参与了支付账单。所以我们建造了木制控制塔，等待着永远不会来的飞机。这就是我们忘记了为什么客观性存在的原因，当我们谈论它时。
The purpose of objectivity is empiricism. The scientific method is to test our own biases. It exists to check us when we're wrong. When the data contradicts our assumptions, we're supposed to update the assumption. That's science. But what we use it for now is just gatekeeping. If something hasn't been researched, it doesn't exist. If something hasn't been quantified, it's not real.
客观性的目的是经验主义。科学方法是为了测试我们自己的偏见。它存在是为了在我们错误时校验我们。当数据与我们的假设相矛盾时，我们应该更新假设。这就是科学。但我们现在用它来做的是守门。如果某事没有被研究过，它就不存在。如果某事没有被量化，它就不是真实的。
If a discovery doesn't fit the existing paradigm, the discovery must be wrong. If you did something that worked and the patient agreed, it worked, and they got better, you must be crazy because that thing hasn't been researched yet. And this is the inverse of science. Using the tools of objectivity to entrench subjectivity, using the method designed to expose blind spots to create new blinds. blind spots and not see them. Porter's work reveals that this is what mechanical objectivity always does when pursued for defensive reasons. Every time across history, since someone scratched
如果一个发现不符合现有的范式，这个发现一定是错的。如果你做了一些有效的事情，病人也同意，它有效，他们好转了，你一定是疯了，因为那件事还没有被研究过。这是科学的倒置。利用客观性的工具来巩固主观性，利用旨在暴露盲点的方法来创造新的盲点，并且看不见它们。波特的工作揭示了这就是机械客观性在出于防御原因被追求时总是做的事情。自有人在美索不达米亚为贸易在泥板上刻下第一笔文字以来，每一次，
the first bits of writing on a clay tablet in mesotamia for trade. Objectivity, objective measurements. They do not always achieve objectivity. They achieve the appearance of objectivity. They create rituals that look like science but function as bureaucratic protection for insecurity. And the exclusion criteria look like rigor, but they're biases in lab codes. And the diagnostic checklist looks like precision, but they're the sacrifice of validity at the altar of reliability. The manualized protocols look like accountability, but they are the elimination of the therapeutic relationship. The only thing that Research consistently shows produces change. CBT does not deconstruct without reconstruction.
客观性，客观测量。它们并不总是实现客观性。它们实现了客观性的外观。它们创造了看起来像科学但作为对不安全感的官僚保护的仪式。排除标准看起来像严谨，但它们是实验室代码中的偏见。诊断清单看起来像精确，但它们是在可靠性的祭坛上牺牲了有效性。手册化的协议看起来像问责，但它们是治疗关系的消除。研究一致表明唯一能产生改变的东西。CBT如果不进行重构，就不会解构。
It strips away false belief, cognitive distortions, maladaptive patterns, but it doesn't add context back. It doesn't provide new containing metaphors. It doesn't help you understand who you are and what you're suffering means. I know the psychoeducation in that book is not the context that I'm talking about. That's the therapeutic equivalent of emptying the temple and walking away. Healing requires a different sequence. Strip the false context, see yourself honestly, and then reconstruct,
它剥离了错误的信念、认知扭曲、适应不良的模式，但它没有把语境加回去。它没有提供新的包含性隐喻。它没有帮助你理解你是谁以及你的痛苦意味着什么。我知道那本书里的心理教育不是我所说的语境。那是清空神庙并走开的治疗等价物。治愈需要一个不同的顺序。剥离错误的语境，诚实地看待自己，然后重构，
build new meaning, find new containers, but you have to give them up first. Absence precedes presence every time. We're doing deconstruction and skipping the reconstruction. We're doing them in the wrong order. A person without context living entirely in the subjective, we're entirely in the objective, stripped of the ability to make meaning through metaphor. That's not health.
建立新的意义，找到新的容器，但你必须先放弃它们。缺失总是先于存在。我们正在进行解构，却跳过了重构。我们做的顺序错了。一个没有语境、完全生活在主观中，或者完全生活在客观中，被剥夺了通过隐喻创造意义能力的人。那不是健康。
That's madness. That's aduduri in the temple. when she weeps. And here's what happens when you empty the temple. The symbol don't disappear. They go underground. They go behind you. They go into your blind spot. And when they come back, they come back as monsters because they're parts of yourself or parts of your system that you're no longer in control of. And those monsters are particularly dangerous when there are things that you can't see that also benefit your insecurity because they make you not face reality in a way that flatters your ego. That's the problem in therapy and that is the problem in research.
那是疯狂。那是阿杜杜里在神庙里哭泣的时候。这就是当你清空神庙时发生的事情。象征并没有消失。它们转入地下。它们走到你身后。它们进入你的盲点。当它们回来时，它们作为怪物回来，因为它们是你自己的一部分，或者是你不再能控制的系统的一部分。当那些东西是你看不见的，同时也对你的不安全感有益时，这些怪物尤其危险，因为它们让你以一种讨好你自我的方式不去面对现实。这就是治疗中的问题，也是研究中的问题。
During COVID, I kept reading the same article over and over written by evangelical megachurch pastors who'd seen their congregations start hearing the call of the internet algorithms and they were getting fed, you know, conspiracy theories and different things. And they weren't coming to church because they'd been on Facebook during lockdown. And the church had abandoned, you know, metaphorical content a long time ago in favor of literalism. And no longer was a containing metaphor. It was just a list of cultural grievances. You know, I saw this on TV and this person lives like this, we know that's not okay. Yeah, it's not okay. That's not a containing metaphor. It's not a transcendent function. And many pastors were just talking about,
在新冠疫情期间，我不断阅读同一篇文章，由福音派大教会的牧师撰写，他们看到他们的会众开始听到互联网算法的呼唤，他们被喂养了，你知道，阴谋论和各种各样的东西。他们没有来教堂，因为他们在封锁期间一直在Facebook上。而教堂很久以前就放弃了，你知道，隐喻内容，转而支持字面主义。它不再是一个包含性的隐喻。它只是一个文化不满的清单。你知道，我在电视上看到了这个，这个人这样生活，我们知道那是不对的。是的，那是不对的。那不是一个包含性的隐喻。它不是一个超越性的功能。许多牧师只是在谈论，
you know, TV and politics and like whatever, making connections about, you know, grand plans to destroy society and it was literal. And so the good and the true containing metaphors that religion used to offer had been dragged out of the temple while no one noticed a long time before COVID happened. COVID simply made people realize that they'd been gone for a while. And so, those symbols rushed back and these pastors all wrote articles being like, you know, I like Trump, I'm a Republican, I'm right wing, but, you know, I'm getting called woke and they're saying that, you know, QAnon is, you know, doing laylines through New Age 5G and Jesus is working with against these aliens for those ones. And I just think the church did a bad job reaching out, you know,
你知道，电视和政治，诸如此类，建立联系，关于，你知道，摧毁社会的宏大计划，而且它是字面的。所以宗教曾经提供的美好和真实的包含性隐喻在新冠疫情发生前很久，就在没人注意的情况下被拖出了神庙。新冠疫情只是让人意识到它们已经消失了一段时间。所以，那些象征涌了回来，这些牧师都写文章说，你知道，我喜欢特朗普，我是共和党人，我是右翼，但是，你知道，我被叫作“觉醒”（woke），他们说，你知道，匿名者Q（QAnon）正在通过新时代的5G做地脉线，耶稣正在与这些外星人对抗。我只是觉得教堂在新冠疫情期间接触他们的会众做得不好，你知道，
to their congregation during COVID. And we need to have a conversation about how you keep the church contained. You know, this is why. happens when you strip context, eliminate meaning, you know, force a retreat into pure objectivity. The subjectivity doesn't disappear. It returns in an unconscious form. You get possessed by archetypes and anything you feel must be true because my subjective intuition is just reflecting everything that I want to think is real back at me. Even my blind spots, even my insecurities. They become manageable because it's this, you know, um, live action RPG that I'm doing. with my life.
我们需要进行一场关于你如何保持教堂包含性的对话。你知道，这就是当你剥离语境、消除意义、你知道，强迫退缩到纯粹客观性时发生的事情。主观性并没有消失。它以一种无意识的形式回归。你被原型所占据，你感受到的任何东西都必须是真实的，因为我的主观直觉只是在反射所有我想要认为是真实的东西。即使是我的盲点，即使是我的不安全感。它们变得可控，因为这是这个，你知道，嗯，我生活中正在做的真人角色扮演游戏。
You know, I'm the one connecting the dots. I'm figuring out the clues. I'm figuring out what Q&N is meaning by decoding this, you know, static noise of the internet. And when people were stuck in their houses looking at the internet, they realized, I can just do this myself. I don't need the pastor. And the idols had already been gone. COVID just made it visible. You know, what's hurting psychotherapy is not CBT.
你知道，我是那个连接点的人。我在弄清楚线索。我在弄清楚匿名者Q通过解码这个，你知道，互联网的静态噪音意味着什么。当人们被困在家里看着互联网时，他们意识到，我可以自己做这件事。我不需要牧师。而偶像早已消失。新冠疫情只是让它变得可见。你知道，伤害心理治疗的不是CBT。
It's the incentive structure that makes the CBT the default mode. that incentive structure exists because of what Porter calls the technology of distance insurance companies can't sit in the room they can't evaluate train judgment and they can't only evaluate where they can quantify and they can't trust you they can only have what can travel across bureaucratic distance which is a number to be audited by people with no clinical understanding and so they reimburse what can be measured manualized protocols symptom checklist treatment plans with objective measurable goals You know, therapists who need to eat, learn to speak that language. And they document in ways that satisfy auditors. And then they provide evidence-based treatment that fit the billing codes. And then off the record, they'll tell you that they don't respect the system and that the system isn't really measuring anything that they do. I'm not saying that, but I hold that for many people.
是激励结构使得CBT成为默认模式。那种激励结构的存在是因为波特所说的“距离技术”。保险公司不能坐在房间里，他们不能评估训练有素的判断力，他们只能评估他们能量化的东西，他们不能信任你，他们只能拥有能跨越官僚距离的东西，也就是一个数字，由没有临床理解力的人审计，所以他们报销可以被测量的东西：手册化协议、症状清单、具有客观可衡量目标的治疗计划。你知道，需要吃饭的治疗师，学会了说那种语言。他们以满足审计员的方式记录。然后他们提供符合账单代码的循证治疗。然后私下里，他们会告诉你他们不尊重这个系统，系统并没有真正衡量他们所做的任何事情。我不是在说这个，但我认为对许多人来说是这样。
You know, the system doesn't need to be this evil. It just needs to be distant. The technology of distance does the work automatically. No one's responsible. So no one really did anything wrong. everyone's just doing their job. It's just how it works. And the result is a lot of licensed practitioners who are not actually doing therapy if they're taking that system seriously. They don't understand what therapy is. They're following manuals instead of encountering persons. And I'm not saying this because they threaten me or I'm mad at them. I'm saying this out of anger for patients because this is the mainstream population's experience of my profession. I'm not criticizing the competition here. These people aren't my competition. We've got a wait list. I don't care what you're doing. I can't. I care. when you're not helping people. And this is what most people think therapy is.
你知道，系统不需要是邪恶的。它只需要是遥远的。距离技术自动完成了工作。没有人负责。所以没有人真的做错了什么。每个人都只是在做他们的工作。这就是它的工作方式。结果是很多有执照的从业者，如果他们认真对待那个系统，他们实际上并没有在做治疗。他们不明白什么是治疗。他们遵循手册而不是遇见人。我这么说不是因为他们威胁我或我生他们的气。我这么说是因为对病人的愤怒，因为这是主流人群对我职业的体验。我不是在这里批评竞争。这些人不是我的竞争对手。我们有等候名单。我不在乎你在做什么。我不能。我在乎。当你没有帮助人们时。这就是大多数人认为治疗是什么。
This is why people get on TikTok or Jordan Peterson videos instead of a medical provider. And yeah, he was licensed one time. He's not a medical provider. He's not a therapist. And the answer to bad therapy is not no therapy. It's just better therapy. You know, I'm deeply skeptical of the idea that therapy is just self-expression or that TikTok and support groups could replace professional treatment because it's all just corrupted
这就是为什么人们会去看TikTok或乔丹·彼得森的视频，而不是去找医疗服务提供者。没错，他曾经拥有执照，但他不是医疗服务提供者，也不是治疗师。糟糕的治疗方案的答案不是放弃治疗，而是寻求更好的治疗。你知道，我非常怀疑那种认为治疗仅仅是自我表达，或者TikTok和互助小组可以取代专业治疗的观点，因为这一切都已经被腐蚀了。
systemic control anyway. And so we should just do whatever we want on the internet. I think that's QAnon. You know, I understand the appeal. After everything I've said about rigged research and hidden biases and hollowed out of professions and therapists that don't know how to do therapy, I understand wanting to burn it all down. But the corruption goes deeper than capitalism, deeper than Big Pharma, deeper than the DSM. It's invaded your assumptions. That's my point. Yours and mine. The way you think about health, the way you think about self, the way you imagine what healing, means that's been colonized. We all inhabit mythology and we all have a temple full of idle whether or not we admit that they're there. And here's what colonization does. It strips you of the
无论如何，这都是系统性的控制。所以我们应该在互联网上随心所欲。我认为那是“匿名者Q”（QAnon）的逻辑。你知道，我理解这种吸引力。在我说了那么多关于被操纵的研究、隐藏的偏见、被掏空的职业以及不懂如何进行治疗的治疗师之后，我理解那种想要彻底摧毁一切的冲动。但这种腐败比资本主义更深，比大型制药公司更深，比《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM）更深。它已经侵蚀了你的假设。这就是我的观点。无论是你的还是我的。你思考健康的方式、你思考自我的方式、你想象治愈意义的方式，都已经受到了殖民。我们都生活在神话中，无论我们是否承认，我们的内心都有一座供满偶像的神庙。而殖民主义所做的就是：它剥夺了你……
creativity to envision something better. It makes you think that the only options are a corrupt system or do it yourself. And it forecloses the possibility that care could be a right, that institutions could serve humanity again, that we're we could take control of them. The people who say, you know, just use crystals or find your tribe or Joe Rogan has a supplement. That's a spiritual bypass. It's not treatment. It's giving you this false empowerment.
构想更美好事物的创造力。它让你认为唯一的选择要么是腐败的系统，要么是自力更生。它排除了这样一种可能性：护理可以是一种权利，机构可以再次服务于人类，我们可以掌控它们。那些说“用用水晶”或“寻找你的部落”或“乔·罗根有补品”的人，那是一种精神逃避。那不是治疗，那是给你一种虚假的赋权感。
It feels liberating, but it's not real. And because when these things get really bad, you know, you're going to want somebody who's a real licensed provider who can work within the objective metrics of the system, but also has somehow saved the subjectivity that the system wanted to drag out. You know, care is a right, not a privilege, and it's not a product, it's a right. And rights require institutions to guarantee them, even when those institutions have fallen very far from what they were supposed to be. And the idols are breaking, and the image comes rushing back. And we can only learn to hold the awareness of the absence together.
这感觉很自由，但不是真实的。因为当情况变得非常糟糕时，你知道，你会想要一个真正的持证专业人员，他既能在系统的客观指标内工作，又能以某种方式保留系统想要抹杀的主观性。你知道，护理是一种权利，而不是特权，它不是一种商品，而是一种权利。权利需要机构来保障，即使这些机构已经远远偏离了它们本应有的样子。偶像正在破碎，真相正在涌回。我们只能学会共同承担这种缺失的意识。
I had to do her he wept because she was alone in that temple and we don't have to be alone the people in the system aren't evil they're scared and they've lost faith in what they can't see and they built wooden airplanes and performed the rituals and wondered why the cargo doesn't come it's not the forms it's not the procedures it's not the checklist or the metrics or the manualized protocols it's the invisible stuff the relationship the meaning the presence, the trained judgment, the honed experience of someone who has sat with suffering and learned something that can't be written in a manual. And Feynman was right. The first principle is that you must not fool yourself, and you are the easiest person to fool. We forgot because
我不得不提到她，她哭了，因为她独自在那座神庙里，而我们不必孤独。系统里的人并不邪恶，他们只是害怕，他们对看不见的东西失去了信心。他们制造了木制飞机，执行了仪式，却纳闷为什么货物没有运来。问题不在于形式，不在于程序，不在于清单、指标或手册化的协议，而在于那些无形的东西：关系、意义、存在、训练有素的判断力，以及一个曾与苦难共处并学到了一些无法写进手册的东西的人所磨练出的经验。费曼说得对，第一原则是你绝不能欺骗自己，而你又是最容易被自己欺骗的人。我们忘记了，因为……
we got scared of what couldn't be counted, and it's time to remember. Stop counting and start to remember the space between numbers. And notice the distance between you and another person. It's all we get. I do Duri wept because she was alone in the temple, but we don't have to be. Little one, where do you go to dream to a place we all know
我们害怕那些无法被量化的东西，现在是时候记起来了。停止计算，开始去感受数字之间的空间。去注意你与他人之间的距离。这就是我们所拥有的一切。我提到她哭了，因为她独自在神庙里，但我们不必如此。小家伙，你去哪里做梦？去一个我们都知道的地方……
the land of make believe? There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那个幻想的国度？本集目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。